what I think about life I think about so
many different things that can factor
into winning the day winning the year
winning the game the five rules that I
live by our confidence I you know
honestly I think self-esteem and
confidence is the ultimate drug in
society and keeps most of us away from
losing scenarios positive Bible only is
a huge one for me because it's not
positive vibes positive vibes only and
that's because many people are keeping
people around them that are bringing
them down they're allowing negative
energy to dictate their outcome and I
really believe that people have to cut
out negative vibes in their environment
Frank's / weaknesses is a big one for me
I preach this all the time
triple down on what you're good at the
world's gonna tell you to fix this
you're not as good as that I just don't
believe in that figure out what you're
best at and keep crafting that crap do
it over and over and over
legacy / currency understand that in 20
30 40 50 years from now you know you're
gonna care much more about what people
thought of you when you're kicked out of
you what the world thought of you did he
do it the right way the dollars the
products that the houses the cars but
whatever you know the monetary things
that don't matter long-term that you're
striving for now don't worry about your
bank account worry about how many people
show up to your funeral and hustle my
friends number 5 hustle if you don't
work hard
you've lost there's not a single winner
on earth that please took it easy
there's not a single winner on earth
just didn't hustle 24/7 365
you